Bundesautobahn 72 ein LKW steht auf der
Straße aber doch nicht auf
Beschleunigungsstreifen es geht um
Trucker die auf Autobahnen parken es
geht um pkw-piloten die etwas zu schnell
unterwegs waren 160 bei 100 und es geht
um Unfallopfer die gerade noch mal davon
gekommen sind
meine Diesel sagt sieben Stunden vorher
René Taubert von der Autobahnpolizei
Reichenbach und sein Kollege Moritz
Zweig kurz vor ihrer Schicht so ich habe
schon alles zusammengepackt hier unser
Ausrüstung für heute
einmal Fototasche einmal Taschenlampe
die Kamera mit dabei
den alten Dame mit dabei die haben immer
mit dabei jeden Tag das gleiche ab 17
Uhr sind die LKW Rastplätze dicht weil
aber die Fahrer ihre Ruhezeiten
einhalten müssen parken Sie fast überall
auch illegal auch gefährlich hier vorne
steht jetzt ein Sattelzug mitten auf
Beschleunigungsstreifen das ist halt
völliger
Weg verstanden wenn ihr jetzt bei der
nächsten Gelegenheit dass die Tank und
Wasseranlage Vogtland Süd mal runter
nehmen in Hoffnung das war doch ein
Platz finden wo wir den kontrollieren
können
ja und dann werden wir mit ihm
unterhalten den Fahrer mal runter nehmen
das heißt überholen ein scheren und die
bekannte Leuchtschrift an bitte folgen
aber bitte folgen haben wir jetzt drin
jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich auch gleich
der klassische bitte folgendefekt viele
Lkw-Fahrer oder Pkw-Fahrer fangen an
tierisch zu schleichen wenn Sie bitte
folgen drinne sehen
immer das gleiche auf dem Parkplatz
Vogtland Süd findet sich tatsächlich
noch ein Platz und somit die Chance für
einen intensiven Austausch rund ums
Thema Parken auf dem Fahrstreifen
Beschleunigungsstreifen was soll das
denn
[Musik]
Beschleunigung Streifen
Adresse
Parkplatz er habe also nur kurz auf dem
Navi die Adresse abgeglichen und das für
höchstens zwei Minuten sagt der Fahrer
seine Technik sagt was anderes
Protokoll jetzt hier laut Auszug vom
Gerät vom digitalen Gerät
Fahrtenschreiber Stange genau 17 Minuten
da
das ist dann schon erhebliches Problem
da werden jetzt auch wahrscheinlich die
Ordnungswidrigkeit Fragen dann auch
anziehen die Ordnungswidrigkeit parken
die die Beamten hier anziehen kostet
etwa 100 Euro der Fahrer muss damit
leben wieder auf der Straße wird es dann
richtig ernst Tempo 100 sind auf diesem
Abschnitt erlaubt ein Audi vor den
beiden liegt drüber und das deutlich und
160 hat er jetzt drauf müssen wir dann
20% Abziehen von den 160 im Schnitt 20%
Abzug weil hier im Auto Messtechnik
fehlt die beiden müssen sich mit einem
sogenannten nachfahrprotokoll helfen
prinzipiell reicht aber in dem Fall das
werden Kilometer hinterher gefahren sind
mit relativ konstanter Geschwindigkeit
er hat sich mehr oder weniger sogar noch
ein Stück von uns entfernt um die 160
gehabt
auch der schwarze audi wird also runter
genommen dass der Fahrer 160 km/h
gefahren sein soll kann der sich kaum
vorstellen
und was viel zu schnell nein
160 bei 100
128 Kilometer pro Stunde bleiben am Ende
übrig also 28 drüber dafür sind 150 Euro
fällig und ein Punkt für jemanden aber
der eigentlich mit 160 unterwegs war
fast ein Schnäppchen
genau so wäre das jetzt ein Videowagen
der sogenannte Provider oder irgendwas
gestanden dann wäre nur ein Abzug von 5
% notwendig gewesen dann werden wir bei
152 km/h 52 km/h zu viel das werden 320
€ 2 Punkte in Flensburg und Einwohner
Fahrverbot also eigentlich ist er ja
noch richtig gut weggekommen die Schicht
ist fast geschafft da kommt noch eine
Unfallmeldung rein also noch mal los
diesmal mit Blaulicht
unterwegs zum Parkplatz großzöbern da
gab es eine Meldung da sollte LKW
Dieselkraftstoff verlieren die Feuerwehr
ist auch unterwegs
genau wissen wo auf dem Parkplatz ob das
eventuell gefährlich ist oder nicht es
ist am Ende nur ein Pkw der Schaden
gering die Ursachen noch unklar offenbar
lag ein Gegenstand auf der Fahrbahn der
auch den Tank aufgerissen hat
keine Ahnung
[Musik]
sofort als er merkte dass er Diesel
verliert steuerte der Fahrer den
Parkplatz hier in Sachsen an der Unfall
passierte aber kurz hinter der
nahegelegenen Grenze zu Bayern die
dortige Polizei wird ihn also weiter
bearbeiten für die Autobahnpolizisten
geht hier ein guter Tag zu Ende trotz
oder vielleicht ja auch wegen der
Bußgelder die sie verhängen mussten also
ich wollte mit guten Gefühl nach Hause
ja konnten dem ein oder anderen helfen
leider musste auch der ein oder andere
ein bisschen bestraft werden das ist
aber ebenso nur so könnte eben anderen
helfen und auch Gefahren beseitigen und
wer weiß wie wir uns heute eigentlich
damit verändert haben nach etwa einer
halben Stunde Rückfahrt haben es die
beiden dann geschafft nun noch auspacken
dann ist endlich Feierabend